[Music]
welcome back everybody to another
edition over the count's corner I'm your
host Kristen Corolla and today I want to
talk about the key moments that impacted
the trajectory of each individual player
in this candidates event and I want to
start with a game between ding mirin and
van ho because in my opinion this is the
game that impacted the trajectory of
Dingley Ren who has been struggling so
far he was one of the favorites
unfortunately for him starting with a
loss with the white pieces simply just
he couldn't recover after that in this
position the critical moment he played
the move f4 which is a horrendous
reticle blunder I will explain to you in
just a second why instead of that he
should have just simply activated his
king with a move King to f3 followed by
king 2e to defend the pawn on d3 as
black you're most likely going to double
up on the D file
try to create pressure on the defiled
I'm going to bring the King to e2 and
slowly slowly I'm going to try to
potentially play the move Bishop to e3
the night is still standing quite nicely
on c4 limiting the bishop on c7 I'm not
going to open up with a move f4 what I'm
going to try to do is actually open up
with a move f3 potentially rook to h1
and maybe at the right moment g4 I don't
have the luxury to hurry up with this
idea and it might just simply not happen
it's not that easy to make progress in
this position black doesn't have as many
weaknesses the only weakness is the pawn
on b7 and it's not that easy to create a
second weakness then leerin hurried with
the move f4 tempted by the prospect of
having a good night against the bad
bishop on c7 as we will see in just a
second
he takes it for Bishop takes f4 night
except for jitae except for right now
optically the position looks very good
because the night
ceefor it looks very very dominant the
problem is it's not about the activity
of the minor pieces in this position is
much more about the activity of the
rooks as well as potential targets for
these rooks and one how seized the
initiative with a move f5 an incredible
move very beautiful more very nice
reticle move you're not going to be able
to take because I'm just simply going to
eat - this probably was missed by the
England because at first sight allowing
me to create a protected passer only
five and completely kill your Bishop on
c7 this looks like strategical suicide
unfortunately for white after route 26
route g6 route to g4 I'm going to be the
first one to stabilize my rook on an
incredible position on g4 attacking the
pawn on f4 and the pond on h4 I'm
getting first to your weaknesses this
rock on a tree is locked to the defense
of the pawn on d3 the roofs are simply
so much better the black groups are so
much better than white swoops and one
who went on to win an incredible game
after that the second game that I want
to discuss is the one between ding-ding
leerin with the black pieces and and VL
and I think this was a very influential
game towards and Will's trajectory in
round two he played this beautiful
opening idea with a move a for this was
seen three times before and black played
the move f6 and we will understand in
just a second why f6 is the right move
and unfortunately for Dingley red he
probably didn't remember his his file or
he just didn't understand exactly the
requirements of the position of course
you don't want to go before because this
diagonal is going to be very good also
after before I'm going to be able to
immediately hook the pawn and if you go
for example a5 I'm going to continue
attacking your weaknesses and after d4
once the e-file opens once my knight
gets to d4
your night on d8 is very easy to see the
difference between the pieces the night
on d8 is a very very bad piece and it's
going to have a very difficult time
finding a good square right now you
don't have any connection between the
ribs this position once the center opens
up is just very very bad for black so
instead of that dinner and play the move
f5 unfortunately for him after f5 he
simply lost lost completely lost after
8xb v 8x b5 rube takes a bishop takes a
c4 and now we see the point of a White's
play if you play the move before I'm
going to simply play Bishop to a4 and
I'm going to get your exchange if you
take on c4 the same thing happens bishop
play for and your exchange is lost now
if you play the move rook to f8 the
difference is that in this position I
have the move Knight takes e5 opening up
this diagonal if you take I'm going to
give you a discovery check that which
Pony 7 is going to be lost and the game
is going to be lost and this is the huge
difference between f5 and f6 for this
reason after a for the right move is f6
ding leerin didn't understand this
didn't remember potentially his files
and he just lost a game without any play
this definitely increased and we are
confident and we see the co-leader right
now is just having an amazing event the
third game I want to talk about is the
one between Fabiano Caruana and Nepal
Mia she Fabiano Khurana has had so far
quite disappointing event he's just
simply not finding his form he's not the
usual kill herself
the one that just simply wraps up his
his claws around you and never lets you
go and this is just simply not happening
and in this game he built up quite a
nice advantage he had very good
preparation as white build up quite a
nice advantage but unfortunately for him
wasn't able to capitalize on it he
played the move Queen to f3 and
unfortunately
to f8 sorry black to move black played
move King to a fate he played the move
Queen to f3 Queen to e1 King to g2 f5
and after g4 I have this cute idea of
defending the pawn on f5 with the Queen
from b1 maybe he missed this idea
Fabiano there is and he allowed black to
equalize instead of that a golden
opportunity presented itself in this
position because he was able to just
simply continue with his plan of
inserting his Queen via g7 King to us a
7 would have been the only move right
now of course if you go Queen to e7 I'm
just simply going to be able to take on
d5 and I'm going to find the perpetual
Queen to d1 Queen to h5 if you hide on
the H file if you hide on the G 2 square
I'm just simply going to go back on d5
so you don't have time to go for the h7
point with your quick but what you do
have time to do is give a check now if I
go King to d7 as black the problem is
I'm getting too far away and I'm simply
going to give you another check if you
go on the dark squares I'm going to
follow up with a check with the bishop
and that's just simply going to be too
many pieces in the attack for example if
you go here if you go have six I have
Queen to e6 which finishes the job and
if you go on the back rank then that's
just simply a checkmate
so unfortunately for him going with the
King on d7 wasn't an option he would
have had to go back to f8 and now this
beautiful maneuver Bishop to d4 I'm
going to bring the Bishop to g7 to force
your King to lock down on g8 going to be
5 is the only move to control the square
e 8 after Bishop to g7
King to g8 now once again I do not have
the checkmate but I can simply just
slowly slowly improve my position I'm
going to play for the only square to
defend against Queen e8 is D 7 then
potentially I'm going to go point to c4
ideas of Queen c6 simply put I have much
more much better prospects of improving
my position while you as black just have
to sit and wait unfortunately for
Fabiano car
he didn't seize the opportunity and he
made a drop and another one another game
that I want to talk about is the one
between Alex Cinco and Geary and I think
this definitely influenced Gary's
trajectory because it was the first game
won by Dutch player in 20 games in the
Candace and that definitely boosted his
confidence in this position the game is
quite an easy draw with with more than
one approach one of them is to go h5
though you might say you might argue
that this is not as is calculate with
one minute on the clock and of course
you know you don't want to give up
potentially a piece after Knight d5 or
f4 so if you don't want to calculate
then you're just simply going to go what
do I want to do I want to get my king to
F where I want to start picking up your
pawns he played a move Knight to d3
which is a huge mistake the right move
and a very beautiful move would have
been the move Knight to H 1 now if you
take my pawn I'm just simply going to go
King to f4 Knight to d5 I'm going to
take on f5 then I'm just simply going to
bring my Knight to e4 and you're not
going to be able to win with just a pawn
on the F file if you try to go for oops
if you try to go for my night after
night to H 1 of course King to f4 you
take I take you go Knight to d5 and this
position is only wide that can win but
of course it's still very easy to after
Knight to e7 King takes f6 Knight to g8
if you go into g 7i to e7 and once you
push I have Knight to f5 but what I'm
trying to say is that after Knight to H
1 it would have been quite an easy draw
unfortunately for Alex anko who is just
simply not finding himself his form he
and see this movie play the move Knight
to d3 and allowed Geary to get his first
victory which definitely influenced so
far his his performance in this event